Pues precisamente qué es lo que sucedió
ese 24 de julio de 2013 es lo que se
quiere aclarar Durante este macrojuicio
que comenzó hoy en la ciudad gallega de
Santiago de Compostela al noroeste del
país donde se dio el accidente esa tarde
un tren de alta velocidad al día
descarriló en una curva a más de 170
kilómetros por hora Cuando en ese lugar
la velocidad máxima permitida era de 80
kilómetros por hora las más de 400
personas perjudicadas agrupadas en 154
acusaciones piden justicia piden verdad
y que se exponga lo ocurrido esa tarde
en lo que denuncian como una cadena de
negligencias además denuncian fallas de
seguridad en la infraestructura de la
línea del tren donde se accidentó ese
vagón la Unión Europea por su parte ya
en un informe en 2016 había asegurado
que la investigación hecha por España
había presentado debilidades y
criticó Perdón la falta de una
evaluación de riesgos en esa curva y la
inexistencia de un sistema de frenado de
emergencia en caso de error humano en
ese tramo de la vía error humano
precisamente hablemos entonces de los
dos acusados en este juicio Y de qué se
les acusa a Marina
pues uno de ellos es Andrés cortavitarte
el ex director de Avis que es la empresa
administradora de las infraestructuras
ferroviarias de España una empresa
pública y por otro lado el maquinista
del tren Francisco garzón a quien
durante años fue el único imputado y
aquí en precisamente esta empresa
pública y los ministerios públicos
señalaban como el único culpable del
accidente
que achacaban a un error humano a un
despiste del conductor puesto que el
conductor Durante los minutos anteriores
al accidente había estado según ellos
distraído por una llamada telefónica a
su teléfono móvil por parte de un
compañero suyo la fiscalía y la sociedad
las asociaciones de víctimas piden
cuatro años de cárcel para cada uno de
ellos que están acusados por homicidio
lesiones y por un delito de daños por
imprudencia profesional grave las
víctimas echan en falta algún
representante de renfe que es la empresa
operadora de trenes de España que esté
sentado en el banquillo puesto que dicen
que ellos también son culpables ya que
un año antes de que sucediera el
accidente es decir en 2012 los el jefe
de maquinistas ya había advertido de lo
peligrosa que era esa curva a esta
entidad Estatal a renfe según las
víctimas además la manera en la que
entraron los acusados en este en esta
sala de juicios señala mucho o es
reflejo de la actitud del gobierno ante
esto ya que el representante del
gobierno de la empresa Estatal Adis
entró por la puerta trasera evitando el
contacto con las víctimas Mientras que
el maquinista del tren accidentado entró
por la puerta principal y pidió